hello welcome back the gang sports
coverage of game of the Year 2015 you're
watching our platform report cards it's
time to talk a bad sony playstation
playstation 4 a pretty good year for
those guys last generation obviously
lagging behind up until the last couple
of years of sort of reached parity at
least in terms of sales justin this year
it seems like PlayStation 4 running away
with us in terms of the the console they
did I mean I'm kind of embarrassed that
I was one of the naysayers a couple
years ago who's saying you know this is
probably the last year for for big
console releases will see something that
maybe meets the success of xbox 360 and
ps3 but PlayStation like PlayStation 4
and Xbox one who wants these apparently
everybody wants if I was totally wrong I
feel like a complete idiot 30 million in
PlayStation 4 sold since its launch in
November 2013 two years ago and it was a
20 million in March that means I've
shifted 10 million units in the past 8
monster and they're effectively like
doubling what xbox is what Microsoft is
doing to the xbox one yeah they've done
it so well that Microsoft has finally
said we're not going to tell how many we
sold yeah yeah let sickness when you
know it's getting ugly obviously one of
the big things in min previous
generations was exclusives specifically
when I think about the heyday of
PlayStation we were talking about Metal
Gear Solid previously you know games
like Final Fantasy Grand Theft Auto
massive massive franchises that existed
on that platform that's not the world we
live in anymore 2015 most of the big
games have come out on most of the
consoles but there were some really
great games and some sleeper hits Alexa
as well I came in yeah until dawn yeah I
remember sitting i did i did a string
with that kind of funny as i remember
saying I on camera like I think until
dawn is going to tank I don't think
anyone cares about it Sony moved it to
summer which is when you release games
to die yeah we crap it is one of my
favorite games this year yes game is so
good it does stuff with with with
narrative design and with player choice
and that whole butterfly affecting that
that telltale like it rivals what
telltale does it rivals what other games
have done and I think that's probably
one of the best games that came out this
year period yeah and nothing and they
had earlier near at Justin blood-borne a
big game for fans I know of the Dark
Souls and demon souls series here in the
office but also for people who haven't
really played those games at all yeah
for someone like me who has been beaten
down by Dark Souls games previously I'm
not a fan
none of that sadistic type of gameplay
but i really enjoy blood-borne like it
is just really solid in the way that it
handles and I love the way that it tells
a story that it's not beating you over
the head with something it's the story
is what you discover as you're going
along which is just fascinating kind of
like destiny destiny in the same way it
doesn't tell you what the story is you
kind of have to figure it out on your
own using interesting choice I mean
we've taken King clearly there's there's
a lot more story going on now and you
mentioned destiny as well the other big
thing I guess what Sony right now is
that they are sort of the de facto lead
platform for a lot of these games they
don't have exclusivity but they do have
dlc exclusive you're getting the 30
already exclusions that Microsoft used
to get they've done a very d yeah they
position themselves as like the go-to
console for all that kind of stuff for
destiny I'm call of duty yeah
battlefront 2 yeah I'm by the front as
well and you can see it across the way
it's not just in terms of the the
content they're getting but it's also in
terms of like whenever you turn the
television on there whenever you see a
commercial for any of these big games
you know anecdotally at least it always
seems to be sony's logo right at the end
of the trailer yeah you can't dismiss
that I mean anecdotal though it may be I
mean that is you know you're not the
only person to notice that it is like
this is a real thing it is the feeling
within the gaming community yeah let's
talk about some of the other exclusives
they had not sure if it really counts to
be honest but journey HD the ona HD but
the remastered version of germans came
out this year and uncharted the
remasters they came out as well actually
god of war coming off master yes
bringing back a lot of those like really
beloved and distinctly playstation
brands which is which has been great i
mean i'm not as exciting as you know
someone like an a sleeper hit like until
dawn but yeah it's great to see all that
stuff come back and you'd have an excuse
to play i mean like i played through
last of us against explode like simply
because i could i got its HD might as
well and like it it's a great excuse to
go back and play some of that stuff so
it certainly hasn't hurt playstation 4
standing in the console war add later
this summer and he also seemed to dip
their finger in the indie book it a
little bit more we didn't see no Matt's
going 2050 and we're going to see it
apparently halfway through next year
everyone's gone to the rapture oh good
good it's very divisive because it's a
walking simulator yes i omit you're not
a real video game election it's good it
was good and then we had axiom verge as
well which is a indie game of the Year
contender for the game wardens so I saw
him play that I have to play that game
she's very well done yes Sony is just
a great job not necessarily of having
exclusives on the indie front but it
making it seem like they do or of
getting a console exclusives and they
have just courted courted the the indie
scene so much especially after Xbox kind
of fell flat in some ways with messaging
and especially the way that they were
talking with Indies they made Indies
feel like I feel at the beginning of the
year at least like that wasn't the
platform for them where Sony was very
inviting and they've Microsoft has
definitely turned that around through
the end of this year but that paid off
dividends until the end of this year now
with Sony making it seem like Bowl this
is the place to release your game yeah
one of the big sort of reasons I feel
like the you know microsoft's were on
the front foot without as well was that
their UI and that their their their
interface for purchasing a want not felt
like it was green I worked on the Xbox
360s and Sony's didn't really feel like
it that way at all in the PlayStation 3
this time I ran playstation store it's
very inviting they got good deals on
pretty eloquently PlayStation Plus is
one of the best like I mean I I'm a huge
fan like I think if you own a ps4 it's
absolutely worth being a PlayStation
Plus subscribe I mean you get so much
league was on us yeah yeah like I
downloaded broken age last month like I
don't think remembers or cared about the
SSX reboot that having a couple years
ago but it's actually like pretty fun
and now you can play it for free like
you probably forgot about it or maybe
never played it now you can just
download it for free like this seems
like this is at least one game every
month I'm like yep I will absolutely
take that excellent great I mean that on
top of being able to you know play
online obviously it's super worth it i
think sony's done a great job of
curating curating quality content for
subscribers decent prices well on
playstation that obviously was launched
in previous years but this year as well
they did some really great deals around
say you know a big game is coming yet so
why don't you play some of the old ones
in the series yeah it gets very smart I
mean my god let's play more Tokyo jungle
in 2015 than probably any other game on
our place cuz it's on that it's on that
system yeah and yeah you dive into that
stuff at all um yeah no I built out my
library this year by just grabbing all
these old games that i missed their
PlayStation Plus and then I probably
would not have bought rocket League
because I'm not a big fan of like online
multiplayer games that game is the best
online multiplayer game out there I
think this year I bet a lot of people
wouldn't have and I think you know as
much as they probably rue the fact that
they gave away the game on ps4 I well
coming back exactly and all that dlc
being sold as well and people are sort
of
able to pick it up as well the
PlayStation Plus has been a great way to
get access to a lot of these games but
sony also has a kind of backwards
approach i think to backwards
compatibility playstation now well
that's yeah about that all I mean I'm
sure for the news recently that like it
does exist and you know battlefront came
with download codes for old ps2 Star
Wars games and so like the technology is
there and it seems like only a matter of
time that makes it more problematic day
this is obviously business decision
that's what PlayStation now is here's a
way that we can monetize this but it's
not the it's not a surprise it's like a
super friendly that's true i mean i
might have i'm secretly hoping that it
changes but I mean you're right it it's
always going to come down to Russia
profit and says you know if ever there
was a library of it's wonderful that
xbox has backwards compatibility but the
Xbox the original xbox only goes back so
far if you think about like wonderful
libraries you know Sega is not around
anymore Nintendo to have their own thing
going on but Sony's got something it's
hard to compete with ps2's library I
mean I think it is bite by numbers that
I just like the largest game library of
any console right we're not going to
give I mean that best we would probably
get ps3 backwards compatibility but even
even being able to access your
PlayStation networking the fact that I
can actually play most of these eats all
my ps3 feels a little bit ridiculous
like I did it might be a screen it feels
that way because it is ridiculous at
least they allowed you to get journey
for free if you'd brought that on
PlayStation still one exception exactly
should I want war stuff like the flowers
and flowers well so that game company or
at least yeah well they're great day for
them if you sit cheaper as well now and
we're down to 350 sticker price of
brandy we've got bundles there for three
hundred dollars devil they said to stay
competitive no the Xbox has been killing
it with with a console exclude with
console bundles yes and we saw that last
month in the NPD s in the US Xbox
outsold the ps4 despite losing every
other month are not every element I mean
they've been back and forth the ps4 has
been ahead but last month it would it
really counted going into the holidays
Xbox one pulled ahead and that's because
no longer the bundles cheaper but they
come with games that you really want my
girlfriend there I mean there are some
great ps4 bundle but you're right they
tend to be games that aren't quite as
desirable I mean charted collection yeah
hey you know what I'd play that be it's
not exactly like you know a real
blockbuster you know it's like Colin
like the fact that xbox comes or
something like the tomb raider like
that's their exclusive yeah yeah that's
mana I really hope that game succeeds I
really really hope they get yes and if
it doesn't you'll be able to play it in
2016 on the PlayStation 4 holidays
inevitably it's good which could be
early year 2017 if we go by holiday
right yeah for sure and last point on
this I guess we didn't see Morpheus it
got renamed to PlayStation 4 we didn't
see it rly station here at least the
PlayStation VR it's it what did I say
you take place work sak sensation for
your punishment yeah that thought that
had said thingy yes with the table and
we didn't see is released this year but
I guess has the messaging changed as of
January 2015 people envy or like we read
in the comments we see it on threads we
read about it on Twitter people getting
so viewers kind of a difficult thing do
you think that now in December of 2015
that it's people are more acceptable and
maybe looking forward to PlayStation 4
your are we still in the same kind of
position I think VR has made huge leaps
and bounds I mean the fact that not only
is this something which is it's not pie
in the sky PlayStation experience is
going to have a huge focus on virtual
reality and it is something that you
have to get into people's hands you have
to like us talking about it as writing
about it doesn't get across the same
experience as putting on a virtual
reality headset and sonia's being smart
they're putting this into public spaces
you can go to movie theaters now and try
out things like oculus and these other
virtual reality experiences the fact
that not only is it just something that
they're talking about on the on the
outskirts this is something that they're
saying this is a full retail product
project there are games that are coming
out for it this is even without
announcing it this is coming out next
year morphia PlayStation VR it's
actually used to or better than I
surname yeah this is they're saying this
is coming out next year's what I'm
reading it to them great year for
playstation ps4 and 2015 will have to
see with 2016 has to offer thanks so
much for coming in Justin lexan Scott
appreciate your time and let us know
what you think of PlayStation 4 in the
comment box below especially you xbox
one owners who are probably watching
this as well don't forget we did one of
those videos already you can watch our
xbox one impressions on gamespot com
right now as well so for more of our
game of your coverage and for more of
our platform report car
rides stay tuned to gizbot com